you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leaches
org and I'm going to play a 15-2 game
let's try let's try an e for a game
okay Sicilian defense all right Knight
to f3 first time playing this opponent
pashka all righty
be six
I don't know if I want to play an open
Sicilian
like c3 or g3
once cat night ce3 in first
see if a black kind of goes flexible
okay well my first thought with d5 is
that I will not be going with g3 because
this position is going to open up fast
there's already tension in the center
and potentially the e-file will open up
so I'm more fixated on simply going
through the door that's already opened
moves to consider I think I need to take
yeah let's take probably end up with
some isolated pawn type position and I
think the way forward is to first play
d4 Wow
very fast that's not why I'm lying
but that is a very weakening move
well
I imagine they've played this position
type before with how fast they're
playing but I feel like a computer would
somehow win this is like already or at
least have a strong pull in an open
position I mean I was saying I didn't
want to devote additional tempo to
deploy my bishop this diagonal is
already opened in there's a some time
being invested on this move so I don't
know if the bishop is really planning to
play to b7 I wonder if they just don't
want to play with an isolated pawn
instead may be preparing to recapture
and have a hanging pawn structure all
right so how do we treat this I'm
thinking about Bishop to b5 and
yeah I'm probably just Bishop to b5 and
castles a quick rook to e1 I don't want
to stay on this file going to d3
I don't know I guess I could go to d3
but there could be c4 so
has to capture if I take here the
cleanest recaptures otherwise I get the
d5 part who
she really I really want to think this
one through because I sense that b6 is
just way off how can i press I feel like
I should be winning upon somehow by
force Bishop takes Queen takes I could
also on this next move I can consider
Queen to e2 captures cling to e2 Queen
block then I could take like if this and
the Queen blocks I could take the knight
has to recapture and then I went out on
d5
so Queen check Bishop here
and I just wind d5 with squeen - e - so
queen - e - if they block with the
bishop for the Queen
[Music]
the Glock with the clean I take the
bishop and then d5 if they block with
the bishop I just take here because now
my bishops defended by my queen
not sure what
this what am I missing
find out
this is illegal
square somehow I think I've I might have
played something like this a long while
ago is black b6 now now I don't think
this exact position types so now not at
their pausing I think they're um yeah
just going to be pointing up upon and
it's going to be an endgame cleans off
and I'm going to be up upon I actually
have the option to no so I'm just I'm
just looking to I first capture on d7 or
do I take here so just two things to
consider
you
Knight takes d5 Queen takes Queen I
would simply recapture with my bishop by
concern what this is there's Bishop
takes bishop
let's see Knight takes d5 I'd prefer to
take take on d5 Knight takes d5 Bishop
takes Bishop Knight takes Queen Bishop
takes Queen we're up a piece in that
current position and both our pieces are
hanging I could take this knife but then
they they take here I don't think that
that variation is working out so
therefore I think we're just going to
take here let's check and now take here
next I don't mind going on Castle
okay
so I'm up upon and the queens are gone
so we consider this an end game
I guess so threading a fork okay
so I just want to complete development I
do this in a smooth way there shouldn't
be any issues with converting this okay
let's try to be as proficient as
possible so
my knight is vulnerable though he should
not be too quick to budge yes let's not
budget this night so fast candidate
moves rook to d1 in c4 I kind of like
this in the event of a check I could
tuck my king away who captures here
c4 I think I like rook to d1 my knight
is unprotected run to d1 takes I can
just take with the night
do have c4 and rip to d1 captures Knight
takes Knight here and I don't get c4 in
I can always just take with the rook to
rook t1 takes I'll take with the rook
there's Bishop c5 but I'll drop all the
way back to d1
probably be the case that their night
has to go here anyhow and maybe the
inductor is getting exchanged let's
start with rook to d1
an endgame
okay so probably just take here yep
let's just take
and
to move away get my bishop out I'm going
to hold on I'm going to keep this
tension I capture I help them to develop
so how about Bishop to g5 anything else
to consider I don't think so
g5
are now connected the check isn't this
wouldn't be a good idea because then
where's he going to go
my king wouldn't mind going to he went
mind being demoted let's say to f1
you know so he's going to have a tough
time if they go for that
so now another option
give up the bishop for night and turn
imbalance be up upon and have a
fantastic square enough five so I feel
like my opponents given me a lot of
things so far just upon and now
something to work with structure wise
I don't know if I even want to give up
that type of in I don't know if I want
to go in for that imbalance to be honest
yeah I do yeah let's let's take another
little advantage here let's take with
the rook
probably bish
b5 here I think I want to keep a book on
I don't want to enter a strictly minor
piece endgame it's still good for me but
I think with these guys split how they
are my real can turn into pac-man okay
so what to do rook to d1 I have a good
spot for my knight do this but Hey
hang on I was talking about this square
right
maybe I should just go there but let's
see if Knight to f5 there's a Czech King
here rook here I don't want to I want to
make sure I minimize any counter play
that my opponent has
let's start with this just continue to
move forward continue to improve if they
put me in a pen I'll play C 3 King and
pawn and games are winning let's put the
King here
and what is the follow-up so c3
defends this but also prepares to maybe
kick the bishop away
okay leaning towards g4g for I think I
like
just to prepare to next anchor the night
here
let's put g4 on
right on
has to be pretty good again the name of
the game for this position type is I
just want to make sure my base points do
not even experience pressure on them I
don't want to I don't want to allow it
to even get to that point here he would
just go there and shove push me away
I want to maintain my pond on g4 I don't
want to capture and allow this the exact
thing I'm trying to avoid even though I
would acquire a passed pawn I don't like
the fact that that rook has some
pressure how would I defend it
conveniently my King would be devoted to
the defense of that so what about b4
here
maybe even rook to d2 with the idea of
maybe trading looks at this stage
now let's hang on how about how about
rook to e4 and then preparing f4 next
excuse me King to e4 check here and then
maybe my rook comes over here to start
attacking pawns here check here a little
role reversal the defense of a d4 point
but something more forceful is maybe
this in fact okay I mean if this rook
leaves this file isn't there going to be
a problem
so what about b4 yeah well this is maybe
a bit too slow how about we just push
here
b4
what to do because if this then I have
c4 then the rook would then have if the
bishop moves somewhere other than d6 I
have this move when the rook moves then
I have some pin in fact I have a winning
idea I'm going to win this game
see for and when the rook moves I play
Knight to f5 or Knight to d5 and it's a
forced forced win
King and pawn endgame being up upon so
let me just double check things here
pretty sure this is a game over move
they have everything on this file c4
followed up with Knight to f5 and that
should be the ball game
there's no their checks there's no
bishop
back my rook c4 it is
they might resign here the only way to
save that piece is this
not even saved because rook here night
here rook here here to defend and I even
pile up some more on the pinned Bishop
with c5 so this isn't a one King and
pawn endgame it's just a boat soon to be
an endgame where I'm up a piece d6
everything is going is going back to
what move is that
be six was moved number five as
mentioned I don't think it was
I had that exact position as black
before but I've done something like that
and okay so they're going to try this
endgame
and it did not turn out well so
technical phase here
different ways to approach this I could
just capture and win the King and pawn
endgame
I am pretty confident that I not open
that but I mean it's not necessary but
it's
yeah I actually see a way where I would
have plenty of a Tempe and I'd mop up
these ponds so maybe even just for
instructional purposes this is a good
approach let's just make sure I
establish first and foremost a strong
King position one pond restricts too
I have this guy I see him as a a
reserved Tempe but in this particular
position I don't really even need to
move this pawn because I could bounce
back and forth on these two squares and
in the end of that will force black to
leave control of f5 and once I'm here
then there's only one Square he could be
on to control f6
so let's do it
King bat for slowly inch my way up to f5
next I'll pick up him and then they'll
have three versus two on the Queen side
and a tomb once I pick up one of these
two two versus one on the Kings side I'm
going to keep these guys sitting
whenever he's challenged stay there so
let's continue on this push I could
capture our advance and this is what I
was talking about these reserve tempie
moves these other approaches I could
just push the candidate past pawn to
Victory Lane
let's get that far
and on this now I could
sure
you
hmm let's just double-check yeah they're
just way too slow this isn't something I
need to calculate take and one they have
one two three four five one two three I
don't have to calculate that what I want
to do here is just simply stop this pond
from getting any further
and they're just going to play this one
out to the end
this attempt to run after that pond is
just not working so I'm just going to
push him now
and one last little trick
and make sure there's no stalemates
now stalemates let's get this check
would be stalemate you don't want to do
that
but we could promote with check next
and that's going to do it just to know
in a in an open position so let's go in
yeah well before I go into the analysis
board there isn't really too much to
there really isn't too much to go over I
was saying at this
Knight to c3 that maybe I go with g3 but
just with one move things changed I put
in if I wanted to put an emphasis on hey
one door is open you're going out that
one you're getting cancelled in every
move I think I move forward in some way
I improve the quality of my pieces and
this just helped me and I think it's
just a losing move it's extremely
difficult to deal with the check and a
quick Queen to e to aisle 2 also notice
it's an open position completely open e
file and black is a long way off from
well they're no pieces were developed so
a long way off from going Kings side and
getting that King to safety this might
just be you know busted move
yes I think this one is just gone
probably have to do something a little
bit different here but you can't no you
block with the nut you're dropping this
so this is just after b6 it's
I don't know maybe a bit too a bit too
much to deal with right I think it's
just losing
we'll see we'll just double-check it let
me put on the analysis board but I think
I'm just winning upon by force so
let's see what is it somebody already
did an analysis where are we at here
still crunching the numbers
it's backtracking goes from the end and
that move 10 we're almost there so let's
see what the final tally is but I don't
throw through the engine right on keep
these two arrows on board d5 is fine but
after b6
plus one point seven plus two growing
advantage Ocala plus two but yeah that's
just guns Oh following up with Bishop to
b5 so where we at final tallies yeah
it's just a b6 that's a opening mistake
you need to I didn't I didn't let
anything slip so much okay was plus two
and then at one point it dropped down to
upon and a half one point two but that's
still
I think that that's still significant
enough let's just kind of breeze through
oh well no not so fast not so fast this
is interesting it doesn't it doesn't
want to go in for a night takes pawn
here Bishop to e3
what's the idea with this to say you're
going to have a very difficult time
completing development because the Queen
gets in the way of the bishop so Bishop
here and if something like this
queenside castle look at how quick my
pieces are coming into play so this is
this is very this is a very brutal
variation every move is deadly it's just
a ton of potential energy and this is
going to be cracked open d5 in the end
will probably fall and then some wow
that's that's pretty cool that's that's
a cool one not grabbing the material
straight away but claiming here you're
going to have trouble completing
development in this position will open
up in my both of my books will occupy
the open file ah okay so that's what the
that's where there was a bit of a dip by
grabbing the pawn instead of playing
Bishop to e3
now that's instructive
I learned a little something right there
okay all right I'm happy with this
decision it likes root 2 d1 c4 I guess
is okay too
I didn't voice it but my initial thought
was to bring the knife back but there's
no reason to run away just yet yeah so
this is this is why there's just this
pawn and a half advantage because I
didn't play that Bishop to e3 move and
yeah this is just gone
we now have three moving forward c3g
three I'm not sure with g3 is about
well right here it likes h3 so just
before this move was played again I
don't want to bring it to this point
this is still some advantage but now
look what I have to do with my King see
it's an end game I want the King in the
center and if he could be closer to the
center and provide support to a pawn if
there's a pond he has to defend I would
prefer he stay in towards the center
somewhere and fulfill that role
even though I have now I pass pawn it's
still a long way off before I could
successfully push this pawn away it's
it's going to take some some more work
if both of these pieces are exchanged
yes bring it on
where I have a a past pun like this so
somehow and I know how to even show this
let's say let's say this move is played
this move here takes takes takes takes
and
okay in this position
you know I would take because I had a
past problem like this but that's not
the greatest illustration that I did
just there but I with pieces on the
board I don't want to work with the rook
on the board with the rook on the board
still that could be putting pressure on
this pawn I wouldn't I wouldn't want to
make this kind of a capture on h5 that's
really the key thing I should be
highlighting with the with the rooks on
I don't want to take like this but what
the rooks off yes even even in a minor
piece endgame I would I would be
capturing like this
suppose their king was over here and
they were able to recapture I would
still do it in that case because I do
get this outside pass pawn but in this
case h3 is fine and this is this is good
then good follow-up I'm glad I
eventually came to that conclusion where
b4 is is good and this is just gone now
putting the King here and the
alternative is rook here
Knight to one of those two and then the
fall of c5 and he's gone and then it's
just a one King and pawn and game in the
end if they tried to
and go in this direction they're just
not going to win the race they're way
too slow but as I play it on this one we
went on to checkmate and that is it v6
as it turns out since the that was the
big lemon and it resulted in a pretty
smooth win
okay as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you're having a great
day and I will catch you soon I just
want to make a quick addendum video here
to the 15 to game I just played I was
curious about my opponent I went into
their profile their name rang a bell
they followed me a while back and it
just - yeah it rang a bell anyhow I went
into the profile and yeah my opponent is
seven years old the game that I just
played my opponent is seven years old
from the Ukraine his name is T own
journey of apologies if I'm not
pronouncing it right they have the
details in their profile I just think
that that is so awesome
then I just wanted to point that out
seven years old and to already have this
kind of understanding of the game that's
just so cool so T hone if you at some
point come across this video keep it up
buddy you have a lot of potential and
that's really really awesome
you played a good game so continued
success is my main point here and that's
all I really wanted to add I think it's
really great to see such a young talent
playing the game so continue
success and yeah that's all I wanted to
add so keep it up buddy
take care